he took
it out oh
for you pftot tuesday edition where we
talk about things we didn't have time to
get to in pft live and today we were
truncated by a half hour due to the
royal ascot that's going to be the and
i've already gotten some complaints from
people via email look we don't look hey
i
we stand down for live sports right you
still get 90 minutes of the show i'm
glad that you're upset that we're not on
but you still have other ways to consume
the content like pftot so we're still
here for a little bit longer not a full
half hour we got some things to talk
about chris it is weird though
that because in the past when we've been
cut short we still had the radio show
that lasted for a half hour and we still
did that this time around we're just
we're just done it's a 90-minute day i
feel like we're stealing money today
i feel like we're stealing money every
day
yeah i'll take it all right 30 minutes
less work same paycheck let's do it i'm
game that sounds good to me
all right well we got a little more work
to do before we wrap up for today and
the two top quarterbacks drafted in 2016
creating some news yesterday one
indirectly won directly first carson
wentz the second overall pick of the
eagles down a man on his offensive line
for the entire 2020 season brandon
brooks out for the year with a torn left
achilles he had torn the right one
previously and we've heard before that
once you tear one
you increase the chances the other one
is eventually going to go for whatever
reason it went he's done for the year
and this is a guy who is very highly
regarded in nfl circus pff had him as
the top guard last year i believe that's
the text pete's sending through right
now let's make sure this is right 2019
first 2018 fifth 2017 third this guy is
a rock on the eagles offensive line and
he's done for the year
and this is one of the byproducts of
guys working out on their own now it may
have happened under the auspices of
working out with the team but but this
this occurs when guys work out alone and
uh it happens quickly it happens not all
that infrequently and it happened to the
eagles and now they're down a key
offensive lineman chris yeah it's a it's
a big it's a big loss i mean you know
you you stated it i mean brandon brooks
has been one of the best guards one of
the best offensive lineman football you
know ever since he got to philadelphia
through free agency a few years ago i
believe he came from houston if i'm
calling that correctly off the top of my
head i mean he's a special player and
you know again there's some moving parts
there in philadelphia that you know this
makes it harder of course you know jason
peters he's gone you know andre dillard
the first round pick from two drafts ago
he's going to be taking over at left
tackle they've lost a few other
alignment and free agencies so
you know that now you're just mixing and
matching a few other new pieces together
to hope this works out and a year like
copenhagen too you know this is one of
those years where you'd really like to
go into camp with a healthy
ready to go hey this is our same
offensive line or mostly the same guys
from last year because yeah you don't
get developed to develop that continuity
and things like that and also you know i
just think with with doug peterson there
and everything like that too man we know
carson wentz plays a little bit of a
reckless style of football uh there's
one other you know issue you have to
worry along those lines too about you
know again the protection's not going to
be as good they're not going to be as
strong and powerful upfront without
brandon brooks
and any tories achilles the first time
around in the divisional playoff game
against the saints in 20 saints right
and and he played every game in 2019 i
mean that's not an extended period of
time to recover and rehab get that thing
surgically repaired get yourself ready
to go and he was still the number one
guard in football according to pff last
year so
from the perspective of an eagles fan
good news he's shown he can overcome an
injury like this bad news he's going to
be out for all of 2020 given the timing
of the injury and it's unclear what
they're going to do larry warford is
still available he was cut by the saints
earlier this year maybe they could bring
back jason peters and shuffle some guys
around he's still available free agency
but uh the eagles have they they have a
challenge now unanticipated
but inevitable stuff happens guys get
injured and lightning struck for the
eagles and uh it's a challenge they're
gonna have to deal with at least they
have time to do it it's always worse
when it happens week one of the regular
season they've got three months to come
up with a plan they've got all of
training camp to get that plan in place
it's much much worse when it happens
early in september than if it happens in
june chris
yeah
there's no doubt about that now i mean
you're not going to replace the talent
of the player but you're right they'll
be able to at least have time here to
formulate a plan and figure out what
they want to do as far as depth of the
offensive line start having
conversations so like what you said mike
how do we want to shuffle guys around oh
we could do this we could do that have a
lot of different contingency plans and
everything like that but you know to me
where it's a blow and you know i don't
know why but i kind of root for the
philadelphia eagles i really like doug
peterson i'm a big fan of carson wentz
i i think too where it's a big blow to
them is
you know
i'd like to have seen them get back to a
little bit of their ways that got them
the super bowl which was play through
the power run game a little bit more and
then the rpos and things off that which
were very effective uh and i feel like
they got away with that last year there
was a lot on carson wentz's shoulders
and you know when things like this
happen i worry that a lot's gonna be on
carson once his shoulders once again um
so we'll see it's a shame that's a big
loss but
it's
in fact mike i'm kind of shocked it
hasn't happened more already just
because you know i i would think you
know guys who knows what they're doing
in this environment training by
themselves how good a shape they're in
you know are they over doing it in a
workout when they're not really ready to
be there or do that type of workout yet
there's no
oh and chris froze up oh we got through
all of the technological difficulties
during the live show and there's chris
look at that one that picture is not as
good
as the one that we use today throughout
the program of the surprised face but i
i think we should save this one and use
it tomorrow
when we unveil number 12 on the chris
sims top 40 quarterback countdown i like
i actually i'm that one's growing on me
fairly quickly the other point we're
going to discuss if we get chris back so
be it jared goff
expressing confidence that the
the truncated season at least the
absence of an off-season program the
limited opportunity to get ready for the
2020 campaign
actually benefits the rams
um
i do think that we have an advantage
offensively with the same system the
same players and everything
um
and and shireen williams and i talked
last week about would you rather have
continuity in your coaching staff
continuity among your players and
cleared this continuity offensively on
the coaching staff for the rams and
jared goff is back and the offensive
line for the most part i think is back
they haven't had any turnover there
andrew whitworth considered retirement
but he returned but todd gurley's gone
brandon cooks is gone
it's not the same players
it's it's not who's your number one
receiver who's your guy that's gonna
command double coverage who's the guy
that's gonna stretch the field who's the
guy that's gonna make it easier to do
the things across the middle and
underneath that that are easier to do
when they're paying attention to brandon
cooks who's that guy going to be
and without todd gurley there to soften
up the offense and we saw what's
happened to that offense since todd
gurley's injury issues have become
and i know he doesn't like people
talking about it but that knee's been a
problem 2017 it wasn't he was the
offensive player of the year 2018 for
most of the year
he was good to go even though he was
fighting through it according to maurice
jones drew he had a strong season late
in the year it became a problem in the
postseason it was a problem and that's
when especially in the super bowl the
rams fizzled out and now gurley's gone
now cooks is gone i don't know that i
would have the same level of confidence
that jared goff has
when it comes to declaring that there is
continuity as it relates to the same
players a lot of the players are the
same but their running game is going to
be dramatically different and i think
that whether or not they have an
effective running game is going to be
a huge factor in whether or not they
have an effective passing game because
the two tend to go together and the
defense is undergoing changes as well
and
those two things tend to go together
because the more pressure your defense
is putting on your offense if your
defense isn't getting the job done and
your offense has more urgency and has to
abandon the running game it becomes
predictable in the passing game and you
don't have a guy who can stretch the
field and command double coverage
and you're in a very difficult division
with the cardinals and the 49ers and the
seahawks
i don't know that i'd be so optimistic
if i was jared goff then again the guy's
making 33 and a half million dollars he
can afford to be however he wants to be
they ain't going to come take the money
away from him worst case scenario is
they decide in a couple of years he's
not the guy until then he's making 33.5
million dollars a year so
either way jared goff wins chris sims
didn't make it back today chris we
missed you in these final few minutes i
tried not to say anything bad about you
i prefer to say the bad things about you
to your face i get a chance to do it
tomorrow morning on pft live 7 a.m
eastern on nbcsn check us out around the
clock at profootballtalk.com
we'll see you back here again today
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports